the big change is happening over at
NBC's Brooklyn nine-nine because when
production finally resumes on the cop
comedy the cast told me the show will
feel a lot different you're talking
about police yeah we're playing cops on
TV and there's now been a call for like
okay let's do away with all cop shows
you know there's no version of cops that
anyone is interested in laughing at or
commiserating with right now it's just
awful so will you address what's going
on in the world right now we've been
having really really deep conversations
about what this new season's gonna look
like the cops of Brooklyn nine-nine are
usually more about goofing off than
getting a message across the name one
time I have an active professional
you're owning a juice box but since
George Floyd's death that's all changed
with production on season eight
currently on hold due to Cova 19
showrunner Dan Gore is getting the
chance to do something he's always
wanted to do address police brutality
Dan literally threw away the first four
episode he's like we just got to start
over cuz this is a new world this is a
new place we are in right now and we
don't want to mess this up we want to
get this right can we joke around
sometimes yes but when it's time to
buckle down we're seasoned professionals
if we had already been way down the road
having written the whole season and even
shot things it would be a lot more
difficult to pivot and change direction
but also hopefully some positive will
come from something very negative week
your hands on your head turn around
don't make any sudden movements I didn't
do anything this isn't the first time
the sitcom has taken aim at social
injustice a 20-17 episode dealt with
racial profiling in reaction to police
shootings that were in the headlines I
got stopped by a cop last night I can't
believe this I mean nothing like that
has ever happened to me and I've done
some pretty suspicious things on the
street I think the best we can do is
educate ourselves as much as possible
you got stopped for being black kid woke
Scully is best part of what the cast
thinks is best donating $100,000 to the
National bail fund network to support
those protesting police brutality
wow man we have a challenge and I but I
believe our writers and our people are
all up to it and I think this eighth
season could be our best ever
[Music]